bonjour bonjour à tous auditrice
auditeurs internautes bonjour federica
et bonjour jimmy manuel césaire bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le directeur du
tropique atrium scène nationale alors
c'est un organisme territorial
organismes satellites de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique organismes de
diffusion et d'action culturelle dont on
rappelle que le conseil d'administration
est présidé par la conseillère
territoriale
christiane emmanuel quelques mots sur
votre parcours votre formation
quelques éléments de votre cv manuel
césaire vous êtes musicien pianiste
auteur compositeur arrangeur vous êtes
aussi enseignant en musique
vous avez été déjà directeur général de
l'ancêtre pour essayer dire du tropique
atrium le centre culturel départemental
atrium et à l'époque c'était le mac
aussi
voilà je me bats voilà c'était entre eux
oui oui vous dit non je dis ce n'est pas
fait pour me rajeunir en objet juste
entre 2006 et 2010 2010 bon c'est pas
c'est parce que ce serait le
prédécesseur alors vous avez été
directeur général voilà et puis on
rappelle que vous avez été vous avez
occupé aussi la fonction entre 2016 et
2018 donc de délégué académique aux arts
et à la culture et vous avez été donc
nommé à la direction de tropiques atrium
que vous connaissiez déjà donc on le
rappelle il ya un an
il ya un an tout juste et vous avez
succédé justement il ya un an hassane
kassi kouyaté
alors comment vous situez-vous par
rapport à cela par rapport à votre
prédécesseur est ce que vous êtes dans
une certaine continuité ou es ce que
vous avez voulu vous placer dans une
rupture
non je n'ai jamais pratiqué la politique
de la table rase et
il faut il faut absolument préserver ce
qui était structuré ce qui a été
consolidée
il faut préserver les succès des
expériences précédentes
voilà hassane kassi kouyaté a fait un
travail très important
déjà sur la mise en route de cette pcc
et sur une redéfinition aussi de ses ses
actions et de ses champs d'activités
avec par exemple un paul important sur
la formation théâtrale des jeunes mais
aussi des amateurs et des professionnels
par contre un directeur et aurait retenu
pour son projet le projet porte en lui
même une identité
donc ce que je ce qui sera plus visible
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement la ligne
éditoriale du projet pour lequel j'ai
été retenu donc nous nous repartons des
des succès et des bonnes recettes de
tropiques atrium et puis mon projet
s'intitule en pluridisciplinarité
assumer nous allons par exemple
accroître le champ effectivement des
différentes disciplines artistiques
ce sera le cas du cirque ce sera le cas
du compte ce sera le cas de la poésie
ce sera aussi le retour des séances
cinématographiques dans le bâtiment sans
pour autant laisser le partenariat que
nous avons avec le multiplex de madiana
ce sera une pluridisciplinarité au sein
de la formation
pas seulement pour le théâtre mais pour
la musique pour la danse pour les arts
visuels
ce sera à faire voilà on a compris dont
vous avez précédé d'ailleurs ma question
suivante
donc c'est effectivement la variété
l'interdisciplinarité que vous avez à
l'esprit quand il a fallu donc élaborer
le programme de cette nouvelle saison en
fonction du projet que vous aviez
présenté doivent être tenus à la tête de
tropiques atrium alors quelques mots
quand même sur l'aspect bon budgétaire
c'est important y compris dans le
domaine de l'action culturelle la
gestion des salles comment vous
entrevoyez les choses
fut un temps effectivement bon bien sûr
tropiques quatrième à toujours proposer
ses propres spectacles mais il y avait
aussi un côté location de salle à tel ou
tel
agents producteurs de spectacles bon de
manière plus ou moins inégal au niveau
de la qualité mais selon les goûts
évidemment mais enfin voilà donc est-ce
qu'on va repartir dans sa ou finalement
ce seront que dès que des spectacles
estampillée tropiques atrium que nous
aurons alors même si nous obtenons vue
historique et chronologique ce bâtiment
a n'a pas été construits n'a pas été
inaugurée en autour d'une activité de
prestation de services ou de location
très rapidement les salles ont été
sollicités par les entrepreneurs de
spectacles tout simplement parce qu'il
n'y a pas d'autres équipements de la
sort donc alors que la martinique est
donc tropiques atrium aujourd'hui est
effectivement très sollicité par les
entrepreneurs de spectacles
nous devons avoir une politique de
structuration du domaine donc nous ne
pouvons pas mes deux côtés de lire
attendait les locations de salles ça
peut participer aux recettes
il ya la billetterie votre propre
billetterie des spectacles vous
produisez que vous invitez et puis voilà
je dirai ce que je vais nuancer le
propos
oui pourquoi parce que
une le coût de fonctionnement par
exemple de la salle aimé césaire dont
qui fait 957 place sur les frais bien
sûr de fonctionnement sur le personnel
mise à disposition sur les intermittents
et 5,6 est intermittent avec une journée
de montage la veille avec trois ou
quatre services le jose bêta on atteint
à peu près les 10000 et 10000 euros par
jour voilà de fonctionnement donc d'un
équipement que l'assortiment
donc quand la salle est louée 4500 4800
en réalité il n'y a pas de de bénéfices
pour la structure mais ce serait plutôt
une perte mais en réalité ça fait partie
de ce travail de structuration du milieu
culturel donc quand cet équipement qui
appartient donc à la collectivité
territoriale de martinique et louer nos
récits tarif là c'est une participation
finalement de la collectivité
territoriales de la martinique
la structuration et au soutien vous que
l'on vous dépassez sur sap ou non mais
ça vient à point je me tirais par
anticipation
alors la ctm participe au budget de
l'organisme pour 3 millions l'état pour
1 million il vous faut quel budget il
vous a fallu quel budget quel est le
montant finalement de la saison que vous
nous proposez là 2019 2020 et bienvenue
lcm nous avons nous avons
établie parce que c'est vraiment un
travail collégial avec les équipes nous
avons établie donc ce projet nous avons
établi cette programmation qui commence
d'ailleurs samedi on va y venir qui à
travers voilà en tenant compte de ce que
nous avons je serais tenté de dire sur
le compte
voyez donc il s'agit surtout pas d' de
construire quelque chose sur des
recettes hypothétique donc nous avons
effectivement un budget que vous avez
donc explicité à l'instant et donc nous
avons tenu compte sur des montants
constant de cette enveloppe actuelle
afin de construire cette cette activité
voulait pas nous préciser le montant
global de la saison c'est difficile à
évaluer que nous avons chez nous avons
un budget qui qui tourne autour de 5
millions d'euros c'est à dire dans que
les les subventions et les recettes
propres et de la billetterie donc je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas compté sur une
hypothétique augmentation du budget donc
nous tenons compte de ce que nous avons
pour faire et car nous sommes pas là je
le redis nous sommes nous seulement pour
avoir une gestion saine des comptes pour
avoir un équilibre donc à la fin mais
nous ne sommes pas là pour dire un
bénéfice finalement de notre activité
nous sommes une scène nationale où un
opérateur public autonome certes mais
public et avec une responsabilité quant
à l'accompagnement quant à l'éducation
quant à la formation dans la diffusion
quant à la professionnalisation
c'est cela avec bien sûr une gestion
saine et transparente des fonds publics
qui sont les nôtres il en vient donc à
cette programmation 2019 2020 alors les
temps forts on pourra pas évidemment de
manière détaillée puis vous aurez
l'occasion de revenir vous quelqu'un de
votre équipe pour en parler d'ailleurs
je rappelle que ce midi il y a le
magazine culturel de notre confrère
fabrice enfin présenté par la rédaction
présenté par fabrice théodose culture
premières et donc il sera question
justement de du rendez vous de demain
qui fait l'ouverture de la saison donc
c'est pas la peine qu'on quand on parle
en détail ce matin par contre donc voila
moi j'ai noté déjà un rendez vous parmi
peut-être les temps forts de cette
programmation rendez vous le 11 janvier
prochain avec haïti notamment la plupart
le oui j'ai mis en exergue parce qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup de temps tout à fait
alors le dès la deuxième semaine du mois
de janvier nous aurons une fenêtre sur
haïti alors il s'agit là aussi c'est à
dire de d'apporter une autre couleur
donc il ne s'agit pas de faire ce qui
est fait pendant l'année donc peut-être
pas d'accueillir les groupes qui sont
déjà régulièrement accueillir la partie
nique
mais nous aurons en danse gens qui
ceinturent avec le crid inago avec plus
d'une douzaine de danseurs avec les
tambours sacrés d'haïti donc le judo
juniors janvier nous aurons une
rencontre avec tous ceux qui vont faire
cette rencontre musicale du samedi 11 et
qui est une commande en réalité c'est à
dire i mean michel gym germe reinette
désir est ouvert à force de
voilà avec avec une passerelle parce que
les artistes haïtiens et de saint
domingue sont très touchés par les
tensions qui peuvent exister entre ces
deux pays qui forment néanmoins seul
territoire une solide et c'est en ce
sens que nous allons accueillir monsieur
omar à fortuna de la république
dominicaine a pour je dirais voilà allez
donc visiter sa souligne cette ouverture
vers la caraïbe enfin tout à fait
spontané naturel finalement pour éviter
toute forme d'appauvrissement qui
découlerait de tout enfermement il nous
faut nous tourner effectivement vers
l'extérieur tant par l'accueil d'un
artiste que également par la circulation
de nos artistes vente unique et c'est
pour ça que pourquoi saint domingue
parce que nous avons établie il ya
quelques mois une convention de
partenariat avec les instances
culturelles de ces nomades
c'est le cas avec haïti c'est le cas
avec les alliances françaises
c'est le cas avec le lot québec nous
sommes actuellement
berne a engagé donc le directeur adjoint
est actuellement à québec en train de
de développer un partenariat afin de
permettre justement des échanges tant
sur les résidences d'artistes que sur la
diffusion donc et naturellement dans
l'ouverture quand nous ouvrons nous nous
ouvrons sur notre zone en fin d un
naturel de prédilection c'est la caraïbe
et là je dirais la grande taille
c'était à la zone caraïbe et amérique et
c'est pour cela que cette fenêtre reçu
haïti j'espère que l'année suivante
bon déjà nous avons durant cette année
nous allons accueillir par exemple la
camerata romeo c'est un ensemble de
musique classique composée d'une de 2,24
musicienne cubaine d'excellent niveau
et donc nous aurons des rendez vous sur
la caraïbe sur l'europe sur l'afrique et
sur les alors justement et il nous faut
conclure alors c'est vrai il s'agit
d'inviter beaucoup d'artistes enfin de
montrer ce qu'ils travaillent ici
d'inviter ceux qui sont voisins ou plus
lointains et puis il s'agit vous l'avez
dit de faire circuler d'exporter aussi
qu'un peu nous nos artistes et donc la
tropiques atrium s'associe avec un
festival s'est associé avec un festival
parisien kiosque orama et lala très
prochainement donc dans des concerts
gratuits ici ou là à paris par exemple
dans le 12e arrondissement le 15ème
arrondissement et ben maher boroy par
exemple va va jouer au square du
commerce dans le 15e arrondissement
nicolas lawson lui au square trousseau
dans le xiième enfin voilà donc il ya
aussi ce souci de coopérer avec d'autres
et c'est la conclusion voulait justement
dit coopération dont il s'agit de la
coopération culturelle pour la
circulation
si on ne coopèrent pas si on établit pas
des conventions de partenariat ont fait
entre guillemets des coûts c'est à dire
des des coûts ponctuels et c est donc il
s'agit vraiment de construire de manière
pérenne des passerelles interactive et
c'est en ce sens que les artistes que
vous venez de nommer son dès demain la
entre
jouer merci et pendant trois semaines
merci manuel césaire bonne journée à
vous tous merci